[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce qu'on mange ce soir une
petite salade de gloubiboulga
certainement pas vous croyez que je vais
vous empoisonner alors je ne vous
connais même pas sûr non pas je crois
que je suis ici pour vous parler d'une
technique de culture ancestrale
pratiquée depuis des millénaires et qui
pourrait nous aider à changer de
paradigme est alors créé cette nouvelle
réalité dont nous serons les artisans
bon alors on mange quoi ce soir pas
d'idées ok je vous propose une petite
salade aquatonic accompagné d'une belle
truite au barbecue
avez vous déjà entendu par les dacquois
pony c'est rarement le cas
vous voyez un poney qui court dans l'eau
eh bien désolée c'est pas ça du tout je
vais vous expliquer la cua pony le plus
simplement possible
mais avant tout je dois vous parler de
choses alarmante et forcément pas drôle
nous savons tous qu'il sera bientôt trop
tard pour agir et faire marche arrière
alors ne nous voilons pas la face ne
nous voilons pas la face et avis sont
chacun à notre échelle localement et
idéalement avec du bon sens parmi les
nombreux défis qui s'annoncent pour
l'humanité le principal va être de tous
nous nous rien d'après la fao
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture
nous serons 9,8 milliards d'humains en
je vous laisse imaginer les problèmes
autre problème de taille la biodiversité
qui réduit comme peau de chagrin et nous
en négligeons encore les effets globaux
rien qu'au niveau des poissons la haye
fao annoncent la disparition massive des
populations marines pour 2048
et c'est problématique parce que nous en
consommons
17 % de nos apports en protéines
proviennent de celui ci est qu'en france
nous en consommons en moyenne 19 kg
chaque année par personne
rien que ces 50 dernières années nous en
avons doublé notre consommation
à l'époque dans les années 70 il était
question de l'aquaculture comme une
réponse à ces problèmes de disparition
des poissons sauvages
à présent nous savons que l'aquaculture
dans la plupart des cas est plus un
problème qu'une solution
mais pourquoi me direz-vous parce que
cette technique nécessite pestis
antibiotiques poisson ogm nourriture
douteuses issues de la surpêche et
destruction des écosystèmes marins à
cause des pollutions qu'elle génère
cette solution n'est pas pérenne autres
autre problème les dernières études
annoncent que en 2050 l'augmentation de
la population et des pollutions diverses
sera telle que nous assisterons à la
raréfaction de l'eau douce il est tout
même question de 50 % d'eau douce
disponible en moins si nous pouvons
économiser beaucoup d'eau et simplement
c'est en améliorant nos techniques
agricoles l'agriculture à elle seule
consomme 70 % de l'eau dans le monde
et oui sombre tableau pour 2050 et 2050
c'est dans 32 ans ça fait peur et puis
comment comment allons-nous réussir à
nourrir l'humanité alors que nous n'y
parvenons déjà pas aujourd'hui la cup
l'aqua pony propose une rep une solution
concrète à ces problématiques de
poissons et d'alimentation je vais vous
parler de ces réalités
l'aqua pony provient de la combinaison
de l'aquaculture qui est l'élevage de
poissons en captivité et de l'hydroponie
qui est la culture de végétaux dans les
solutions
nutritive hors sol ces deux techniques
sont largement connues pour les
pollutions qu'elle génère de par leurs
problématiques de traitement
antibiotique engrais pesticides et bien
sûr le gaspillage d'eau occasionnées par
contre en combinant ces deux techniques
vertes polluantes
nous arrivons à créer un véritable
écosystème vertueux qui peut presque
s'autosuffit et permet de cultiver
sainement tout en réduisant notre
recours aux intrants cerise sur le
gâteau la cua pony permis une économie
d'eau de 90% d'eau par rapport à la
culture conventionnelle et 90%
c'est énorme je vous recommande ce slide
en aqua pony nous avons un trio gagnant
de plantes de bactéries et de poissons
les poissons salissent you pour nourrir
les plantes et les plantes elle elle
purifie l'eau pour les poissons
cela grâce à l'aide des bactéries qui
transforme
l'ammoniaque en nitrites et les nitrites
en nitrates et les nitrates ce sont tout
simplement les nutriments dont les
plantes ont besoin pour s'épanouir
au final les plantes les poissons et les
bactéries travaillent nuit et jour pour
nous alors se poser la question de ce
qu'est ce qu'on cultive comment avec
quelle technique pour les cultures
toutes sortes de plantes potagères pour
les poissons tous types de poissons de
douche et ce dans n'importe quel endroit
où climat en ville et à la campagne en
tant que président de la fédération
française dacquois poli j'ai participé à
la création de nombreux projets qui vont
du petit système familial et domestique
installé dans le salon dans le garage
dans la cuisine sur le balcon jusqu'à la
création de serres maraîchères de
plusieurs milliers
deux mètres carrés nous voyons
maintenant de la cua pony dans les
écoles dans les salles de repos des
entreprises dans les restaurants et un
petit peu partout je vois vraiment de la
cua poli à toutes les sauces et je peux
vous assurer que ça fonctionne tenez
pour vous donner une idée sur notre
climat français et avec seulement 1500
mètres carrés nous pouvons espérer
produire environ 25 tonnes de fruits et
légumes ainsi que 5 tonnes de poissons
chaque année c'est assez pour nous rien
un quartier des cantines pour fournir 10
restants vous pour vendre sur les
marchés sous nos climats
il faut compter environ 1,7 kg de
nourriture donnée aux poissons pour
produire un kilo de poisson
magique non mais alors c'est quoi les
désavantages à quoi pony baryons n'a pas
aucun des avantages
aucun des avantages mis à part qu'il
faut s'y connaître un petit peu en
poisson est un petit peu en plantes pour
que pour que vous réussissiez à bien me
suivre je vous propose un voyage en aqua
pony êtes vous prêts fermez les yeux et
inspirez profondément vous êtes dans
votre salon et profiter des derniers
rayons de soleil après une douce et
agréable journée en face de vous votre
vieille aquarium transformer en système
aquatonic vous entendez le doux bruit de
l'eau vous sentez les effluves de vaud
aromatiques récemment plantés visualiser
la symbiose de vos poissons évoluant
dans l'aquarium à côté de vos plantes
soyez fiers de vous
ce soir vous pourrez déguster vos
premières tomates au basilic cultivée
par vous même à l'aide de ce cercle
vertueux
allez réveiller vous et revenons à la
technique vous allez voir c'est simple
la cua pony repose sur un écosystème
pour nourrir les poissons
vous pouvez soit élevé des verts ou des
insectes dans votre compost soit acheter
de la nourriture adaptée
vous pouvez même cultiver des algues ou
des lentilles d'eau pour varier les
apports des poissons transformer les
déchets organiques en trésors pas mal
non
alors se pose
ah oui alors alors bien sûr la cua pony
l'incarnent
alors bien sûr là la cua pony n'incarne
pas à elle seule les problèmes les
réponses aux problématiques évoquées
précédemment mais elle s'inscrit
définitivement dans l'agriculture du
futur et notamment dans l'agriculture
urbaine grâce à ses nombreux avantages
vous ne vous en rendez peut-être
toujours pas content mais il va falloir
entièrement repenser nos vies si nous
voulons survivre il va falloir produire
plus avec moins
j'entends par là produire plus
d'aliments sains en consommant le moins
de ressources possibles tout en prenant
en compte le respect de l'environnement
et de la biodiversité sur lesquelles
repose notre espèce à l'heure actuelle
80 % de la population française et 55%
de la population mondiale vivent en
ville et la réponse à ces enjeux va
principalement des coulées de la
résidence alimentaire et de
l'approvisionnement de celle ci en
produisant et en consommant localement
en circuit court
nous pourrons réussir à éviter la
catastrophe et nous réussirons à recréer
cette boucle vertueuse
avez vous un petit peu le trac vous ne
vous en rendez
vous ne vous en rendez peut-être volvo
volvo vous ne vous en rendez peut-être
pas compte mais un véritable
bouleversement social découle de ce
genre de projet réinsertion sociale
apprentissage du partage respect et
compréhension du vivant échanges de
services rencontres échanges
intergénérationnels amélioration du
bien-être et de la santé et j'en passe
c'est un véritable raz-de-marée d'amour
et de bienveillance qui peut s'abattre
sur votre ville j'espère que ma petite
histoire de salades vous a fait
comprendre que nous n'avons plus le
temps de nous en raconter soyons soyons
la solution à nos problèmes et agissons
maintenant quand on s'aime c'est pour la
vie
[Applaudissements]